yeah it's just like scout camp man that  food was terrible there's a one time  they gave a Salisbury steak do you ever  stop talking what I wouldn't give for  little cells were a steak now hey Ray  Palmer  put your hand down he might know where  Vostok is keeping the professor shut up  and eat do you know if there's any other  place where they keep prisoners here  we're looking for a friend there is a  place they send you there you'll never  come back  you can hear the screams all night this  place where is it you see it you could  eat hey he's not hurting anybody who is  this American with the pretty teeth  let's be a comedian  ah sure we can handle this like adults  sukkah  DC's legends of tomorrow new hit series  tonight and eight seven central on the  CW  you